hi I'm Eric Voss and as we wait for the
Walking Dead's eighth season to return a
lot of you guys been asking us about
Carl
Koral in the mid-season finale and
before I go further obligatory spoiler
warning though at this point anyone who
cares about the Walking Dead already
knows about this cool Grimes has been
bitten Rick is a mess
fans have lost their minds and producers
have found a way to make people who have
already stopped watching the show turn
around to be like who's dead now coral
has not died yet however according to
the actor in the show he will appear in
one final episode when season 8 returns
but this is for real people cast and
crew have made public goodbyes to
Chandler Riggs who himself has spoken a
lot about moving on with this career
Riggs his father voiced his frustration
when the show killing him off right
before his 18th birthday and right after
they bought a house in Georgia to be
closer to the show's set but but but
what if I know that's crazy yeah okay
fine what if the show isn't being
totally sincere with us what if we're
looking at another Glenn dumpster fake
out if you remember the cast and crew
then gave interviews seeming to say
goodbye it is Steven Yeun just to bring
him back to life a few episodes later
and then kill him off a few episodes
after that Wow I don't think the show
would play with our emotions again like
this and maybe it's too much wishful
thinking let's dance with some
conspiracy theories and discuss the
interesting scenarios by which quarrel
could survive other than you know
returning to the ocean and rejoining his
reef theory number one coral is a mutant
I touched on this in my breakdown in the
mid-season finale but in the past some
fans have suggested that coral could be
immune to the zombie virus in real-world
epidemics it said that 1% of the human
population is naturally immune to viral
infections if the Walking Dead follows
that logic it could be possible that
Coral Grimes possesses that genetic
irregularity and that while other
people's immune systems are prone to
infection corals Wolverine level
regenerative immune system could
miraculously survive all major injuries
this theory has been brought up before
and I think it's popular with fans one
ting an end game to the comics and TV
series like you can imagine a scenario
where corals immune blood is used to
produce a cure or a vaccine and
re-stabilize the human population of
course comic creator Robert Kirkman has
said immunity is
never a possibility he wants to
entertain in the comics orange show
because his vision for The Walking Dead
was a zombie world with no possibility
for salvation how society would have to
evolve indeed these days on the show
it's more about the wars between
post-apocalyptic human tribes with
walkers becoming more of a background
threat which is why it was kind of nice
to see one of those routine Walker
scuffles actually have consequences for
a character that said if the show is
willing to deviate from the comics in
this major way to kill off coral who
becomes a major player in the future of
these storylines in the comics it could
indicate a willingness to deviate when
it comes to the possibility of immunity
if not for this character maybe someone
further down the line let's move on to
the second theory and focus because this
is very serious but what if the Walker
who bit coral wore dentures wait come
back come back now for this we'll need
to do some crime scene analysis on the
moment that coral was supposedly bitten
it happened back in episode six
remember when he helps Sadiq clear a few
walkers I guess to honor their moms I
don't know just go back and watch my
breakdown of why the hell they were
doing this the Walker that bites coral
pins him against a dead elk he struggles
with it shoves it off and then another
comes in for a kiss then the first rules
back on top of them goes in for a belly
raspberry and then the camera cuts back
to city next we seed coral in a close-up
wind zine and pain and then pulling out
a gun to plug the two walkers and then
he catches his breath and shock stands
up looks down at his side and grapples
with this realization looking back at
the biter got him those pearly whites
look a bit perlier whiter than what you
would expect from a deteriorating corpse
who uses its teeth for pretty much
everything and probably doesn't get too
much calcium in its diet suggesting
these could be prosthetics or veneers
sitting in let's be realistic here this
is a stunt actor probably wearing dental
inserts to darken his gums so I don't
really know how well we can judge these
teeth that we're seeing also like other
diseases that can be transferred through
bites like rabies or HIV the infection
actually passes from the transmitters
saliva into the recipients bloodstream
after the bite breaks the skin it
doesn't come from the tooth itself like
snake venom from the fangs but hey it's
still fun to talk about a zombie with
dentures right it's just a really great
image final theory involves a spoiler
for something happens after these
current events in the comics so be
warned okay another possibility is that
corals bite came from
a human not a walker either a scuffle
with a savior that happened off camera
or more interestingly old pearly whites
wasn't actually a walker he was a
whisper in the comics the whispers are a
tribe of people who disguised themselves
by wearing Walker skins they're
nicknamed whisperers because they
initially freaked people out when they
can be heard whispering to each other
make anything that while curse can talk
Ricinus people run into these guys after
the time jump that comes after the war
with the Savior's and looking closely at
the Walker that got coral you can kind
of make out a line around the eye hole
separating the outer layer of skin from
the inner one but yeah like with that
denture theory this is an actor playing
a zombie wearing makeup in a prosthetic
mask actually I do feel like I have to
stress this because I think some Walking
Dead viewers get this zombies don't
actually exist guys it should
scientifically impossible you you don't
have to worry about zombies survival
plans really pause the zoom and enhance
on any Walker in the show and you'll
start to see these kinds of details so
it's hard to know if we're seeing TV
show makeup or a post-apocalyptic tribe
with somehow a TV shows budget for masks
at the end of the day guys I think we
should all assume Karl is indeed done
for remember the season 8 premiere
already hinted that Rick would soon face
some devastating loss
and I think only losing another family
member could fill Rick's eyes with grief
like this and for those of you who think
that the show is squandering an
opportunity to explore this
post-apocalyptic world through the eyes
of a young person who grew up within it
they could do that with Enid they can do
that with Judith as she grows up they
can do that with any new young character
they decide to add to the cast this is a
TV show they can do whatever they want
I'll admit that post savior's era coral
in the comics does go on some very
interesting directions but Chandler
Riggs his version the character always
seemed to me to be more of a foil for
Rick so in my eyes it's fitting that he
goes out that way with Rick's response
to losing coral being the thing that
defines Rick Grimes as a man and maybe
that will just be Rick screaming over
and over again do it with me
ah but I'm curious to hear from you guys
is the idea of a cure something you'd
ever want to see in the walking dead
well hurt look into things more
generally just the walking dead ever in
I'll let you guys chew on that in the
comments below you can also tweet me
directly at Els and follow a new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates under videos like and share this
video and subscribe to new rock stars or
deep dives into all the episodes of The
Walking Dead and if you really like us
some want to help this channel grow you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
Matthew salvos thanks for watching
[Music]